[Musique]
les chevilles ce soir c'est un grand
événement dans tpm parce que nous
recevons la personnalité de l'année le
professeur didier raoult le spécialiste
des maladies infectieuses reconnu dans
le monde entier et qui a beaucoup fait
parler de lui depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire
déjà je vous dis va écouter ce que vous
dites qu'est ce que vous pensez du
professeur à où tous ici dit la vérité
franchement jean-michel moi j'ai jamais
caché que voilà je comprenais jamais cet
engouement auprès du professeur raoul je
ne nie pas du tout qu'ils soient très
brillant le premier scientifique on
n'aime pas les sur ce débat là mais sur
le point de vue moon médiatique je
trouve ça un imposteur
voilà de tout transpire la suffisance
l'arrogance dont alors il entend ce que
vous dites un des bâtons mais je le dis
pour qu'ils entendraient vraiment voilà
rien la passion la première fois ai-je
entendu parler de lui ces compagnies de
son look l'île à l'automne social mais
il a dit j'ai fait ça pour emmerder les
autres d autres scientifiques rinçage du
si donc le mec commun il est barré il a
un complexe de supériorité veut pas
ressembler aux autres et à force de ne
pas vouloir ressembler aux autres
eh ben on nage à contre-courant comme
les saumons donc on dit quelque chose
idy la verte et souvent malheureusement
quand tout est d'accord vous êtes à
contre-courant vous avez tort et le run
et qu'est ce que vous répondez à ceux
qui critiquent l'eau je ne tire pas de
même pris place laurier lacroix
l'unanimité alors il a accepté de venir
mais c'est pas l'unanimité ici dans
l'est c'était d'aller où il fait pas
l'unanimité ici fibre est très bon à
vrai dire on ne fera aucun original il
est comme il est tu le prends comme il
est
et tu sais c'est le pauvre 0 il ya
toujours dit que je les dis l'auto en
été on parler de ça lui il a déjà pas de
deuxième vague mais si la majorité des
français ça c'est comme pour pour faire
des conneries c'est comme si tu sur une
route il ya marqué mballo 50 à l'heure
en tout la salle canne accident c'est la
fois pato la fois que tu dit camille le
panneau tous les français sont conduites
intelligentes
les français sont assez cons pour
permettre de trucs mais oui pour pas
mettre le masque est tout aussi des
vagues au hall à mieux à la télé suivez
bo hansen a et b l'apéro au mois de juin
quelqu'un ait aidé comme finis sont
arrivés à brasser locaux master et au
fmi
ils seront en vente à paris nice et
paris qu'un bouc année ils feraient
mieux de sortir un peu de son bistrot il
doit dépasser cette journée quelle masse
et à les masser ils ont vous serez que
tu es un sauveur il passe dans la rue
klaxonnent
mais y'a pas que les marseillais dans le
monde dans le monde entier il également
[Rires]
j'étais
mais qu'elle voulait mais tu t'es dit
toi tu un job astres alors quand il
vient à paris n'est qu'il est obligé de
se déguiser non pas que l'on reconnaisse
comme un jeu de piste de glisse mais le
mec qui veut avoir une chance moment vol
chez lui il n' ya pas qu il l a su que
la dernière je n'arrêtais pas lui il est
incapable de le reconnaître
il n'y aura dans un instant vous verrez
et quand je vous dit il au dessus vous
dites et je vais vous n'êtes pas tendre
avec lui
mais voilà il n'est pas tendre avec vous
non plus gilles qui est couronné tilly
n'importe quoi c'est le professeur à au
viol et au stone et charden hugo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les problèmes
lui qui met une photo la topolino et que
nous emmerde et céline chef
[Applaudissements]
on y voit là j'étais comme j'habitais
pas dans ton bras se côtoient dit on va
accueillir le professeur à ou alors non
mais pas l'accueillir dans cet état oui
jamais deux parties mardi à m'excuser à
celui qui me prennent en photo même pas
fini sortie dès demain d'accord alors
rené vous lirez votre poème ou confiseur
à ou quand il va rentrer voilà je veux
le dire a marché parce que j'aime pas
lui croyez vraiment qu'on va faire venir
fogar aller si on paie j'aimerais qu'on
respecte les règles erronées je sais pas
s'il va vouloir coulisses des poèmes pas
c'était pas prévu jeudi que vous le
diront merci professeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien sûr vous connaissez vous surprise
pour nous je parle plus là parce que
l'on reconnaît type a est ce que vous
voulez la surprise du professeur mes
défauts n'est pas la gare
[Applaudissements]